schauen wir gemeinsam auf das grauen von
butscher paul dort war sie dort ein bild
vor ort gemacht und wir wollen auch mal
gemeinsam sehen wie diese kleinstadt
früher einmal aussah vor dem krieg
die idyllische grünanlagen parks
spielplätze
einfamilienhäuser
gutbürgerliche wohngebiete rund 35.000
einwohner eine kleinstadt in der region
kiew etwa 25 kilometer von der
hauptstadt entfernt
das war
vor einiger zeit noch
heute sieht die stadt so aus
[Musik]
verwüstung
zerstörung
vernichtung
unendliches leid
[Musik]
was ist was diktator putin hinterlässt
und bei mir weiterhin paul ronzheimer
der uns diese bilder auch mitgebracht
hat in butter auch war deshalb zu einem
großen aufschrei geführt in der welt
paul die sanktionen sollen verschärft
werden doch ist das ausreichend was
sagen die menschen in der ukraine
als ich gelesen habe dass die
europäische union jetzt die kohle
importe oder die exporte verbieten will
von russland nach europa ja mag ein
anfang sein aber ich habe mir dann
vorgestellt patricia was wäre wenn
eu-vertreter jetzt in butter sein würden
da wo wir zwei tage waren wenn sie dort
auf dem platz stehen würden die
zerstörung sehen leichen sehen und den
menschen den butscher erklären würden
dass das ihre antwort ist auf das
kriegsverbrechen wo hunderte menschen
abgeschlachtet wurden ich glaube die
menschen sind butscher die würden
ausrasten
das ist jetzt die antwort die man
bekommt auch präsident seelands gerhard
die eine einladung ausgesprochen darüber
sprechen wir gleich noch hier im zuge
der sendung funktionen dass also die
antwort für die menschen die in butscher
vor dem nichts stehen noch mehr als das
sie stehen mitten in der hölle dort was
glaubst du paul wie wird es weitergehen
in den nächsten tagen man kann aus der
strategie putin zu wenig ablesen es
heißt er würde sich jetzt auf den osten
konzentrieren gleichzeitig ist in diesem
krieg auch klar geworden man kann auf
kein wort vertrauen was sagen die ja
auch deine informationen dort aus kiew
vielleicht noch ein wort zu den
sanktionen patricia was ich sagen wollte
ist es die sanktion nicht hart genug
sind also kohle export einschränken das
reicht nicht die regierung hier die
verlangt gas und öl und das ist das
worauf und wartet als zeichen so viel zu
den sanktionen die frage des
militärischen ja die bewegte natürlich
viele ich habe heute mit mehreren
regierungsvertretern sprechen können und
habe mit ihnen auch über die
militärische lage geredet dort heißt es
dass man in den nächsten tagen eine neue
offensive im osten befürchtet das könnte
sich dann um die städte sabrina und die
protoss der name kommt immer noch schwer
über die lippen obwohl ich seit 2004
zieht dorthin fahre und kharkiv
passieren und das muss man auch so klar
sagen kiew das war eine festung hier gab
es luft abwehrraketen abwehr hier waren
die besten soldaten und sind
wahrscheinlich noch immer die besten
soldaten denn der präsident ist hier
kiew die hauptstadt das ist das symbol
aber die anderen städte sind nicht so
gut geschützt wie hier deswegen auch
dieser dramatischen appell der
ukrainischen politiker dass man jetzt
sofort neue waffen braucht um diese
städte schützen zu können verteidigen zu
können und immer wieder auch die
forderung nach dem kompletten energie
embargo paul ronzheimer vielen
herzlichen dank für deine informationen
aus kiel